Prof: So we're talking
now about mortgages and how to
value them,
and if you remember now a
mortgage--
so the first mortgages,
by the way,
that we know of,
come from Babylonian times.
It's not like some American
invented the mortgage or
something.
This was 3,500-3,800 years old
and we have on these cuneiform
tablets these mortgages.
And so the idea of a mortgage
is you make a promise,
you back your promise with
collateral,
so if you don't keep the
promise they can take your
house,
and there's some way of getting
out of the promise because
everybody knows the collateral,
you might want to leave the
home, and then you have to have
some way of dissolving the
promise because the promise
involves many payments over
time.
So it's making a promise,
backing it with collateral,
and finding a way to dissolve
the promise at prearranged terms
in case you want to end it by
prepaying.
And that prepaying is called
the refinancing option.
And because there's a
refinancing option it makes the
mortgage a much more complicated
thing,
and a much more interesting
thing, and something that,
for example,
a hedge fund could imagine that
it could make money trading.
So I just want to give you a
slight indication of how that
could happen.
So as we said if you have a
typical mortgage,
say the mortgage rate is 8
percent--
maybe this is a different
answer than I did--
so here we have an 8 percent
mortgage with a 6 percent
interest rate to begin with.
Now, if it's an 8 percent
mortgage the guy's going to have
to pay much more than 8 percent
a year because a mortgage,
remember, there are level
payments.
We're talking about fixed rate
mortgages.
You pay the same amount every
single year for 30 years,
now you're really paying
monthly and I've ignored the
monthly business because it's
just too many months and there
are 360 of them.
So I'm thinking of it as an
annual payment.
You have to pay,
of course, more than 8 dollars
a year because if the mortgage
rate were 8 percent and you had
a balloon payment on the end,
you'd pay 8,8, 8,108.
That's the way they used to
work, but they were changed.
So you could imagine the old
fashioned mortgage would pay
8,8, 8,8, 8,108;
if you didn't pay your 8
somewhere along the line they'd
confiscate your whole house and
then take what was owed out of
it and you could get out of it
by paying 100.
The new mortgages instead of
paying 8 every year for 30 years
you pay 8.88 every year for 30
years because if you discount
payments of 8.8 for 30 years at
8 percent you get 100.
So the present value is 100 at
the agreed upon discounting rate
or mortgage rate 8 percent.
And so you see how important
this discount rate is.
And the remaining balance,
however, goes down because
every time you're paying you're
paying more than the 8 percent
interest.
You're paying in the first year
8.8 instead of 8 and so that gap
of .88 is used to reduce the
balance from 100 to 99.117.
And so you see the balance is
going down over time and making
the lender safer and safer
because the same house is
backing it.
So it's called an amortizing
mortgage.
Now, why is it difficult to
value?
Because you have the option,
any time you want,
and there's a good reason for
that option,
any time you want you have the
option of getting out of the
mortgage and just saying,
"Okay, I've paid 3
payments of 8.88,
I don't want to do it anymore.
I want to pay off 97.13 and
then let's call it quits."
And they say,
"Okay,"
and there's nothing they can do
about it.
Now, when are you going to
exercise that option?
You're going to exercise that
option either because you have
to move,
that's the intention of it,
or you'll exercise it when it's
most advantageous to you.
Now, why could it become
advantageous to exercise it?
Well, you don't really want to
exercise the option and this is
the way most people think of it
backwards.
They think, "Oh,
the interest rates are going
down.
That means I'll get a new
mortgage with a lower interest
rate."
They're hoping for exactly the
wrong thing.
If the interest rates go up
what they've got is a much
better mortgage because they're
continuing to buy at the same 8
percent interest and maybe
interest rates in the economy
have become 12 percent and
they're actually making money.
So people who borrow in times
of high inflation do better.
When there are times of
deflation the borrowers get
crushed.
Irving Fisher said one of the
main reasons for the Depression
being so bad is all the
entrepreneurial people in the
country,
as usual, were borrowing,
and then there was a deflation
and so they were getting
crushed.
And the very people who drive
the economy were being hurt the
most.
And so that feedback,
he said, was responsible for
part of the severity of the
Depression.
So you see interest rates can
go up or down and what happens?
When they go up,
if they go up high enough to 19
percent you think,
"My, gosh,
I've made a fortune holding
this mortgage.
I'm still borrowing at 8
percent and I can invest my
money at 19 percent."
So you've made a fortune and
the poor lender's gotten
crushed.
On the other hand if the
interest rates go way down here,
so the present value of what
you owe if you kept paying it
becomes huge,
you don't have to face that big
loss because you just prepay at
whatever the remaining balance
is there and then you've
protected your downside.
So by paying attention and
deciding when the optimal time
to prepay is,
you can save yourself a lot of
money and thereby cost the bank
a lot of money.
So when exactly should you
prepay?
When should you exercise your
options?
Well, in this example if you
never exercised it you'd be
handing the bank,
effectively,
120 dollars even though they
lent you 20 [correction:
lent you 100].
So the bank would have made a
20 percent profit on you.
But if you exercise your option
optimally you're going to make
not 100--
the bank is not going to get
100 dollars out of you,
they're going to even get less
than 100 dollars.
They're going to get 98 dollars
out of you.
So when exactly should you be
exercising your option?
Well, we went over this last
time.
I'll do it once again.
So remember,
the payment you owed was
8.88,8.88, blah,
blah, blah, 8.88.
The remaining balance started,
of course, at 100 and then it
went down to 99.11 and then it
kept going down from there.
So since I can't remember the
numbers let's just call this
B_1,
the remaining balance which
happened to be,
you know, it was 99.11 the
first time.
Let's call this B_1,
then I went to B_2,
B_3 etcetera and then
B_30 is equal to 0,
no remaining balance after that.
So we said, what should you
do--I'm going to do the
calculation now a little bit
differently--
I said after every payment of
8.88 you could always say to
yourself,
"Do I want to continue or
do I want to pay my
option?"
Now, you notice that if I had
divided this by B_1,
say, if you had a mortgage that
was a little bit smaller,
barely over a 1 dollar for
example,
that would divide everything by
B_1.
The payments would all be
divided by B_1 and the
remaining balances would all be
divided by B_1.
So I could always scale this
thing up or down.
There's nothing fancy about
100, nothing important about
100.
If the original loan was for
200 you just double all your
payments and double all your
remaining balances.
What could be more obvious than
that?
So I want to think in those
terms of a mortgage that always
has 1 dollar left.
So suppose at any stage you had
1 dollar left in your mortgage.
Your remaining balance was 1.
So let's say at any node,
let's ask the question,
what is the value of 1 dollar
of remaining balance?
So if you start at 100 and you
haven't prepaid,
here you've got B_2
dollars.
Of course, whatever the value
of that is divided by
B_2,
that's the value of 1 dollar.
So I'm just going to figure out
the value of 1 dollar of
remaining balance and I'm going
to call that W,
let's say.
I'll call that W of some node S.
So where am I?
I'm in some node in this
interest rate tree,
right?
Here's our interest rate tree,
and I'm anywhere just here,
and I'm doing backward
induction so for all successor
nodes I figured out what 1
dollar of remaining balance is.
And let's say it's in period
1,2, 3,4, 5, so I'm in period 5,
B_5.
So what is the remaining
balance at this node which I
call S?
So it's some node right there
of--oh no, I've lost it.
So W_S is going to be
what?
It's going to be the minimum of
1, you could just pay it if you
wanted to, or you could wait.
1 over (1 r_S),
and then what would you have to
do, you would have to make your
payment.
Well, what's your payment?
The payment is this 8.88 but
divided by B_5 plus
the remaining balance of 1
dollar.
So (B_6 over
B_5) times the
remainder times W_Sup.
Now, why is this right?
I hope it is right by the way.
I should have thought of this a
little before.
So this is the remainder of 1
dollar left.
So if I divide by B_5
here I'm not going to have a
remaining balance of
B_6.
I'm going to have a remaining
balance of B_6 over
B_5.
So if I started with 1 dollar
of remaining balance then I know
that in the next period I'm
going to have B_6 over
B_5 dollars of
remaining balance left.
It doesn't sound too
convincing, by the way.
Well, it's right,
and that happens with
probability 1 half.
And then with the other
probability 1 half,
plus I make the payment,
but I go down instead of up and
so I have B_6 over
B_5 but I have
W_Sdown,
and that's also times 1 half.
So either I pay off my
remaining dollar or I end up
with this many dollars.
Assuming I had a 1 dollar of
remaining balance I'm either
going to pay it off,
the remaining balance,
or I'm going to have this much
left next period and 1 dollar of
remaining balance is going to be
that.
So that's it.
So I know now by working this
backwards I can tell what 1
dollar at the beginning is
worth.
And so it's exactly the same
calculation I did before except
I'm talking about 1 dollar.
I'm always figuring out 1
dollar of remaining balance
instead of the whole thing.
Present value of callable,
so here's present value of 1
dollar of principal.
And so remember the present
value of a callable mortgage was
98.8.
Here the present value of 1
dollar,
figuring it out that way,
is .98, obviously it's divided
by 100,
but the key is that now you can
see just by looking at it where
the 1s are is where the guy
decided to prepay.
So it's the same thing as
before, but you see before you
couldn't tell very easily from
the numbers when I did the 100.
Sorry, that didn't quite make
it.
Before when I did the present
value with the 100 all these
numbers were 98s and 97s.
I mean, where has he prepaid?
It's hard to tell where the
prepayment is.
If I do it all in terms of 1
dollar of remaining balance then
just by looking at the screen I
can tell where the guy prepaid
because there are 1s there.
So I know where he's prepaid.
Wherever the 1s are that means
he's prepaid.
So I can tell very easily what
he did.
All right, that's the only
purpose of doing the same
calculation in a somewhat
trickier way.
So if you think about it a
second you see I've just divided
by--I've always reduced things
to if you had 1 dollar left.
All right, so this tells us
what to do, when the guy should
prepay and when he shouldn't
prepay.
So if you're now in the world
looking at what's happening you
can find the historical record
of how people have prepaid.
So let's just look at the
historical record,
for example.
Here, if you can see this,
this is blown up as big as it
goes.
So this is what you might see
as the historical record of
percentage prepayments
annualized from '86 to '99,
say.
So you notice that they're very
low here, and then they get to
be very high,
and then they get low again,
and then they get high again.
So why do you think that
happened?
So what is this?
This is prepayments for a
particular mortgage,
8 percent.
You take all the people in the
country who started in 1986 with
8 percent mortgages.
There's a huge crowd of those
because that was about what the
mortgage rate was that year.
So a huge collection of people
got these mortgages in '86 and
you keep track of what
percentage of them prepaid,
really every month,
but you write the annualized
rate,
and then this is the record.
So why do you think it changed
so dramatically like that?
What's the explanation?
Student: Stock market.
Prof: What?
Prof: It looks like the
stock market,
but I assure you the stock
market had almost nothing to do
with it.
Why would prepayments be so
low, and then be so high,
then be low,
then be high?
What do you think was happening?
Student: Interest rate
change.
Prof: Interest rate.
We just did that.
We just solved that.
That was the whole point of
what we were doing.
So you tell me,
what do you think happened in
'93?
This is September '93.
I don't know if you can read
that.
What do you think was going on
then?
Student: Interest rates
got low.
Prof: Interest rates got
low, exactly.
So you may not remember this
because you were barely born.
In the early '90s there was a
recession and then the
government cut the interest
rates.
In the '90s,
the early '90s there was a
recession and the government
kept cutting interest rates
further, and further and
further.
There was this huge decline in
interest rates through the early
'90s, and so what happened?
All these people who,
in '86, who had these 8 percent
mortgages--the new interest
rates were lower and so they all
prepaid.
You got this shocking amount of
prepayment.
So this graph,
which seems sort of surprising
and looks like the stock market,
turns out to have nothing to do
with the stock market.
It has to do with where the
interest rates are.
Well, do you think interest
rates explain everything?
No.
What else could you notice
about the--escape.
What else have we learned here
by doing these calculations?
Well, what we've learned so far
is that if the interest rates in
the economy are at 6 percent,
that's where they started,
remember we said they started
at 6 percent and there was 16
percent volatility.
Here I had 20 percent
volatility.
It doesn't matter.
I mean, that's a plausible
amount of volatility,
a little high,
but that volatility.
The mortgage rate of 8 percent
is not going to give a value of
100.
It's going to cheat the bank if
the homeowners are acting
rationally.
The bank could get 120 if the
people weren't acting
rationally.
They were just never exercising
their option.
It they're exercising their
option optimally the thing was
only worth 98.
Now, I told you at that time
the interest rates should have
been around 7 and 1 half
percent,
not 8 percent given this 6
percent interest rate in the
economy.
The mortgage rate should be 7
and 1 half percent.
So we deduced last time that
obviously not everybody's acting
optimally.
Well, you can tell that looking
at this diagram.
How do you know that not
everybody's acting optimally?
Remember these are '86
mortgages, so everybody's taking
them out at the same time within
a few months of each other,
the same 8 percent mortgage.
How can you tell from this
graph that they're not
exercising their option
optimally?
It's completely obvious.
Just looking at it for one
second you can say,
"Oh, these people can't be
exercising their option
optimally,"
why is that?
Yes?
Student: They should be
exercising all at the same time
if they were acting rationally.
Prof: So as he says
we've just done the calculation
with those 1s and 0s.
I told you when the right time
to exercise the option is,
so, everybody's got the same
circumstance.
Every single person if all
they're trying to do is minimize
the present value of their
payments they should all be
prepaying at the same time.
Here you see that very few
people are prepaying,
but it's getting up to almost
10 percent so probably this is a
stupid time to prepay,
but the point is still 10
percent of them are prepaying.
And over here when presumably
you ought to prepay,
in the entire year,
right, they have 12 chances
during the year.
It takes them an entire year
and only 60 percent of them have
figured out that they should
prepay.
So you know they're not acting
optimally.
So just from that graph that
would tell you,
and you have further evidence
of that.
That's evidence that they
aren't acting optimally.
Furthermore you have evidence
that the banks don't expect them
to be acting optimally because
the banks aren't charging them 8
or 9 percent interest,
which is what they would need
to pay to get the thing worth
100,
they're charging them 7 and 1
half percent interest which for
the optimal pre-payer is worth
much less than 100 to the bank.
So the banks wouldn't do that.
They would just go out of
business if they did something
stupid like that.
They wouldn't do that unless
they thought that the homeowners
weren't acting,
at least not all of them
acting, optimally.
So suppose you had to predict
how people are going to act in
the future and you wanted to
trade on that?
What would you do?
How would you think about
predicting it?
So this is the data that you
have.
What would you do?
You have this data.
These are 8 percent things.
You also have 9 percent
mortgages issued the year
before,
and then maybe a year before
that there were 8 and 1 half
percent interest and you have
that history,
and you've got all these
different pools and all these
different histories.
How would you think about
figuring out a prepayment--how
would you predict prepayments?
Well, the way economists,
macro economists at least in
the old days,
used to make predictions,
they would say,
"Hum, the first quarter
looks pretty good."
What are they predicting now?
Now, they're saying
unemployment is probably going
to keep rising for the next
quarter or two well until the
next year,
but at that point things are
going to turn around and we
expect the economy to get
stronger,
come out of its recession and
unemployment should gradually
improve from its high which we
expect will be 10 and 1 half
percent to something back down
to 6 percent by the end of 2011.
That's more or less the
economists' prediction.
Now, can you make a prediction
like that about prepayments?
Would it make sense to make a
prediction about that?
Why is that an utterly stupid
kind of prediction?
What is the essence of good
prediction?
If you wanted to predict
something and you were going to
lose a lot of money if your
prediction was wrong how would
you refine your prediction
compared to what I just gave as
a sample prediction?
Yep?
Student: You have to
have a number of scenarios and
>
to each one.
Prof: Exactly.
So what he said is if you're
even the slightest bit
sophisticated you're not going
to make a bald non-contingent
prediction.
Things are going to get worse
the next two quarters,
then they're going to start
getting better,
then things are going to get as
well as they're going to get
after two years.
You'll solve the problem after
two years.
What happens if another war
breaks out in Iraq?
What if Iran bombs Israel?
What if there's another crash
in commercial real estate?
How could that prediction
possibly turn out to be true?
It's a sure thing it's going to
be wrong.
It's just impossible that's
going to be right because the
guy making the prediction has
made no contingencies built in
his prediction.
You know that guy's making a
prediction for free.
Someone may be paying him to
hear him, but he's not going to
be penalized if his prediction
is wrong.
No one in their right mind
would make such a prediction.
So the first thing you should
do in predicting prepayments is
to realize that you've got a
tree of possible futures,
and given this tree of possible
futures you're going to predict
different prepayments depending
on where you go on the tree.
So you see, prediction is not a
simple one event--it's not a one
shot thing.
Just as he so aptly put it,
it's a many scenario thing.
You have to predict on many,
many scenarios what you think
will happen and that makes your
prediction much better because,
of course, if there is a war in
Iraq,
and if there is a catastrophe
in Afghanistan,
and if Iran does bomb Israel,
and if the commercial real
estate market collapses things
are going to be a lot worse than
this original guy's prediction.
So everybody knows that,
so why not make the prediction
more sensible?
So, on Wall Street that's what
everybody's done for 20 years.
Now, they haven't done it for
30 years.
It's just 20 years that they've
been doing that.
So when I got to Kidder Peabody
in 1990 they were making these
one scenario predictions.
It's a long story which I'll
tell maybe Sunday night.
I ended up in charge of the
Research Department and so we
made, you know,
other firms were doing this
already, we made scenario
predictions, okay?
So now what kind of scenario
predictions are you going to
make?
When you make contingent
predictions there are an awful
lot of them.
You can't even write them all
down, so what you have to do is
you have to have a model.
So what kind of model should
you have?
I'll tell you now what the
standard guys were doing on Wall
Street at the time.
They were saying--here's
interest rate,
sorry.
Here's the present value of a
mortgage.
callable mortgage,
present value of 1 dollar of
principal, so realistic
prepayments.
So if we go over here we'll see
that people said,
"Look, from this graph
it's clear,"
they would say,
"that when interest rates
went down people prepay more so
why don't we have a function
that looks like this?"
So, prepay, that's the
percentage of remaining balance
that is paid off.
So what does that mean?
Remember, after you've made
your coupon payment you have a
remaining balance,
B_5.
You could pay all of it,
or none of it,
or half of it.
So the prepay is what
percentage of the
B_5--that's just after
you've paid, right?
So, B_2 lets do that
one.
B_2,
just after you've paid 8.88 the
remaining balance has now been
reduced to B_2.
You could, in addition to the
8.88, pay off all of that
B_2.
Typically some people who are
alert and think it's a good time
to prepay will pay all of
B_2.
Others will pay none of
So if you aggregate over the
whole collection of people the
prepay percentages,
out of the sums of all their
B_2s what percentage
of them are going to pay off.
So we look at the aggregate
prepayment.
That's the old fashioned way.
And we say, "What
percentage of the remaining
balance is paid off?"
So you'd make a function like
this.
You'd say, "Well,
prepaid might equal 10
percent."
Why am I picking 10 percent?
So if you go back to this
picture you see that prepayments
seem to be around 10 percent
when nothing's happening.
So you say 10 percent plus
maybe you're going to get some
more prepayments so you might
write--well, I just wrote down a
function plus the min.
The min, say,
of .60 because it never seems
to get over 60 percent if you
look at that you see it never
gets over 60 percent really.
So the min of 60 and 15 times
the max of 0 and (M -
r_S - sigma over 133).
That would be a kind of
prepayment function.
So what does this say?
What happens?
You're normally going to
pay--so this is this whole
function here,
so I should write this as .1
plus, can you see that over
there,
maybe not, so this plus .1.
So there's a baseline of 10
percent and if the interest rate
is high,
so the interest rate is above
the mortgage rate no one else is
going to prepay because this is
going to be a negative number
and this will be 0.
So you're just going to do
.1,10 percent.
On the other hand,
as the interest rate gets low
and falls far enough below the
mortgage rate people are going
to say to themselves,
"Ah-ha!
I have a big incentive to
prepay now.
Maybe interest rates have gone
down so far I can no longer hope
they're going to go back up
above the mortgage rate.
I should start prepaying
more."
So more people are going to
prepay and this thing is going
to go up.
I just multiply it by some
constant, but it'll never go up
more than 60 percent.
That's what this function says.
And sigma, this is the
volatility--all right,
so let's just leave that aside.
So there's a prepayment
function that seems to sort of
capture what's going on.
It's usually around 10 percent
when there's no incentive.
It never gets above 60 percent,
but as the incentive to prepay,
as interest rates get lower and
the incentive to prepay
increases,
more and more people prepay.
That's kind of the idea.
All right, and then you would
fit fancier curves than that.
You would look at M -
r_T and you would fit
a curve that looks like this.
So if there's just a little bit
of incentive to prepay,
the rates are a little bit
lower than the mortgage rate,
nobody does it.
Then quickly a lot of people do
it and then they stop doing it.
So this is like 60 percent and
most of the time you're around
10 percent, and you try and fit
this curve.
You're going to have millions
of parameters and since you have
so much data you could fit
parameters.
That was the old fashioned way
and that's how people would
predict prepayments.
Now, that's not going to turn
out to be such a great way,
but it certainly teaches you
something.
So let's look at what happens
if you now--with those realistic
prepayments you compute the
value of a mortgage.
So this is the prepayment that
you'd get for the different
rates and so you can see that as
the rates go down the total
prepayment is going up.
And by the way,
it's more than 60 percent
because you've got this 10
percent added to the 60 percent,
so the most it could be is 70
percent,
which it hits over here.
So you get 70 percent as the
maximum prepayments,
and as interest rates get
higher no one prepays except the
10 percent of guys.
Now, by the way,
why are people prepaying over
here even when the rates are so
high?
It's because some people are
moving or they're getting
divorced and they have to sell
their house.
So obviously you're going to
get some prepayments no matter
what.
People have to prepay,
and why is it that people never
prepay more than 60 percent
historically or 70 percent,
because not everybody pays
attention.
Now, I called them the dumb
guys last time,
but as I said,
I probably fit into that
category.
It's people who are distracted
and doing other things.
They're just not paying
attention and so they don't
realize.
They don't know what's going
on, so they don't realize they
should be prepaying.
So as interest rates go down
more people prepay.
As interest rates go up less
people prepay.
And if you did some historical
thing and figured out the right
parameters you'd get a
prepayment function.
So how did I figure out this
was 15?
How did I figure out this was
.6?
Why should I divide this by 133?
What's sigma?
Once you get those parameters
historically you now have a
well-determined behavior rule of
what people are going to prepay,
and from that you can figure
out what the prices are of any
mortgage by backward induction.
So how would you do it again by
backward induction?
The same we always did it.
Over here, what would you do
over here?
How would you change this rule?
Well, you would just be feeding
in the prepayment function.
So what would the prepayment
function be?
Well, people wouldn't be doing
a minimum here,
right?
They're not deciding whether or
not to prepay,
they're just prepaying.
So let's get rid of that.
They're prepaying.
So this is the value of 1
dollars left of principal.
So some of them are prepaying
and that's the function,
so prepay, and that depends on
what node you're at.
And here it says what
percentage of the remaining
balance is being prepaid.
So that tells you,
that rule, who's prepaying,
and then with the rest of the
money that's going on until next
time 1 minus that same thing,
1 minus prepay times exactly
what we had before.
So this part of 1 dollar got
prepaid immediately so that's
the cash that went to the
mortgage holder.
The rest of the cash got saved
until next time and here's what
happens to it.
You have to make your coupon,
then you have a remaining
balance, and then whatever is
going to happen is going to
happen.
So you'll study this and you'll
figure out I'm sure.
It takes a little bit of effort
to see that through,
but with half an hour staring
at it you'll understand how this
works and you'll read it in a
spreadsheet so you can figure
out the value of a mortgage.
You get a value of a mortgage,
and now we can start doing
experiments by changing the
parameters and see how the
mortgage works.
Now, before I do that I want to
say that there's a better way to
do this.
I mean, maybe these numbers are
estimated--what's a better way
of doing it?
How did I do it at Ellington,
how did we--I mean at Kidder
Peabody?
How did we predict prepayments?
What's another way at looking
at prepayments?
Let me tell you something
that's missing.
I used to ask people who wanted
to work at Kidder Peabody or
Ellington the following little
simple puzzle,
and most of the genius
mathematicians always got this
answer wrong.
Of course we hired them anyway,
but they'd always get this
wrong.
So the question is,
suppose you've got a group of
people like this and you figure
out what the value of the
mortgage is,
and interest rates have been
constant all this time.
Let's suppose for one month
interest rates shoot down,
interest rates collapse and
half the pool,
60 percent of the pool
disappears.
So now you've only got 40
percent of the people left you
had before, and then interest
rates return to exactly where
they were to begin with.
Should the pool that's left be
worth 40 percent of the pool
that you had just here,
or more than 40 percent,
or less than 40 percent?
So remember,
you had 100 people here.
You're the bank who's lent them
the money.
You're valuing the mortgage
payments they're going to make
to you,
you're getting a certain amount
of money from them,
60 percent of them suddenly
disappeared in 1 month leaving
40 left,
but now interest rates are back
exactly where they were before.
Is the value of the mortgage
starting here with the 40
percent pool worth 40 percent of
what it was originally,
more than 40 percent or less
than 40 percent?
What do you think?
Yes?
Student: Is it worth
more than 40 percent because
those people don't understand
interest rates and therefore
they're not
>
option properly and
their mortgages?
Prof: Exactly.
So that's an incredibly
important point.
It's called the opposite of
adverse selection.
Every one of these events is
selecting the people left not
adversely,
not perversely,
what's the opposite of
adversely,
favorably to you,
so the guys who are left are
all losers,
but that's who you want to deal
with.
You don't want to trade with
the geniuses.
You want to trade with the guy
who's not paying any attention.
So the guys left are the people
who are never going to prepay or
hardly ever going to prepay and
so it's much better.
Now, this function doesn't
capture that at all,
right?
It doesn't say anything.
It just says your prepayment's
depending on where you are.
So whether you were here or
here you're going to get the
same prepayment,
but we know that that's not
going to be the case.
In fact, it's clear that over
here there must have been a much
bigger incentive than there was
over there.
So the prepayments are the
same, but actually interest
rates here were vastly lower
than interest rates there.
So this is not such a good
function.
So how would you improve?
What would you do to take into
account this adverse selection,
or actually pro-verse
selection?
What is the opposite of adverse?
Well, it doesn't matter.
What would you think to do?
Your whole livelihood depends
on it, millions,
trillions of dollars at stake
here.
You've got to model prepayments
correctly, so how would you
think of doing this?
Just give me some sense of what
a hedge fund does or what anyone
in this market would have to do.
Well, most of them did this.
So what would you do?
Yeah?
Student: Buy up old
mortgages, because the market is
probably under estimating their
value.
Prof: Well you would buy
it up when?
Student: Right after...
Prof: Right here you'd
buy it up, right there,
but what model would you use to
predict prepayments?
Not this one,
so how would you imagine doing
it.
You would imagine making a
model just like your intuition,
so what does that mean doing?
Someone's asking you to run a
research department,
make a model of forecasting
prepayments.
All the data you have is
aggregate data like that.
You can't observe individual
homeowners in those days.
They wouldn't give you the
information.
I'll explain all that Sunday
night.
So this is the kind of data you
have, what the whole group of
people is doing every year,
but what would you do to build
the model?
Adverse selection is very
important or pro-verse
selection.
It's embarrassing I don't
remember the word,
favorable selection,
a very important thing.
So how would you capture that
in your model?
Yep?
Student: Would you split
it into two groups and then
model it separately?
Prof: So maybe another
thing you could do,
what if you instead of having
this function that says what the
aggregate's going to do all the
data's aggregate,
so all you can do is test
against aggregate data.
But suppose you said,
"The world,
all we can see is the
aggregate, but the people really
acting are individuals acting,
not the aggregate.
It's the sum of individual
activities, so what we should do
now is have different kinds of
people."
Oh gosh, sorry.
It was there already.
So let's go back to where we
were before, so realistic.
What you ought to do is you
ought to say,
well, 8 percent--remember we
had two kinds of people already.
We've already got two kinds of
people, sorry.
We've got these guys,
the guys who never call,
so they're people.
That's a kind of person.
And suppose you go down here
and you have the people who are
optimally prepaying?
Suppose you imagine that half
the people were optimally
prepaying and half the people
never prepaid?
Well, would that explain this
favorable selection?
Absolutely it would explain it
because when you went through
your little tree and you went
here,
and here, and here,
and here, by the time you got
down here all those people,
all the optimal pre-payers
they're all prepaying.
So you start off with
half-optimal guys and
half-asleep guys.
Once you get down here all the
optimal guys have disappeared
and the pool that's left is all
asleep,
so of course the pool is worth
much more here given the
interest rate than it was over
here.
In fact, if it goes back then
again to here where it was
before--sorry that's same line.
If it goes back to here--have I
done this right?
No, I've got to go back twice
here and then here.
So once it goes back to here if
it goes here,
here, here and here then the
pool is going to be much more
valuable here than it started
there.
There are half as many people,
but it's worth much more than
half of what it was there.
So the way to do this is to
break--so then you're looking at
the individuals.
You're saying one class of
people is very smart,
or one class of people is very
alert, it's a much better word,
one class of people is very
alert.
One class of people is very
un-alert and as you go through
the tree the alert people are
going to disappear faster than
the non-alert people and that's
why you're going to have a
favorable selection of people
who's left in the pool.
Well, of course,
there are no extremes of
perfectly rational or perfectly
asleep in the economy so what
you can do is you can make
people in between.
How do you make them in between?
Well, suppose that,
for example,
I only did one thing.
Suppose it's costly to prepay?
Some people just say to
themselves, "I'm going to
have to take a whole day off of
work.
I'm not going to write my paper.
I might lose some business that
I was going to do that day.
A whole bunch of stuff I'm
losing, so I'm going to subtract
that.
I'm not going to prepay.
I'm not going to even think
about doing it unless I can get
at least a certain benefit from
having done it."
So you can add a cost of
prepaying and people aren't
going to prepay unless the gain
that they have by prepaying
exceeds the cost of doing the
prepayments.
So to take the simplest case
let's suppose the very act of--
never mind the thinking and all
that--
the very act of prepaying,
going to the bank literally
costs you money.
So if you have a value,
if the thing is 100 and you can
prepay,
you know, if you do your
calculations and don't prepay
today it's worth 98 and if you
prepay today the remaining
balance is 94 you're saving 4
dollars,
but if the cost of prepayment
is 5 you're still not going to
do it.
So you get a guy with a high
cost of prepaying,
an infinite cost of prepaying,
he's going to look like he's
totally un-alert.
A guy with zero cost of paying
is going to look like he's
totally alert.
So you can have gradations of
rationality, and you can have
different dimensions.
So you can have cost of
prepaying and you can have
alertness.
What's the percentage of time
you're actually paying attention
that month?
What fraction of the months do
you actually pay attention,
and you can have a distribution
of people, different costs and
different alertnesses.
So that's the model that I
built.
It's a simplified form of it.
It gives you an idea.
So here's this burnout effect
that I showed that if you take
the same coupons,
but an older one rather than
a--an older one that's burned
out will always prepay slower,
so the pink one is always less
than the blue one because it
went through an opportunity to
prepay.
So here you start with a pool
of guys on the right,
and then after a while,
after time has gone down a lot
of them have prepaid.
So here's alertness and cost.
So you describe a person by
what his cost of prepaying is
and how alert he is.
The more alert he is and the
lower the cost of prepaying the
closer to rational he is.
The less alert he is,
the higher the cost of
prepaying the closer to the
totally dumb guy he is.
And so you could have a whole
normally distributed
distribution of people and over
time those groups are going to
be reduced because a lot of them
are prepaying,
but they won't be reduce
symmetrically.
The low cost high alertness
guys are going to disappear much
faster and the pool's going to
get more and more favorable to
you.
And so anyway,
all you have to do is
parameterize the cost,
what the distribution of people
in the population,
what the standard deviation and
expectation of cost is and of
alertness is,
and that tells you what this
distribution looks like.
So you're fitting four numbers
and you've got thousands of
pools and hundreds and hundreds
of months,
and fitting four parameters you
can end up fitting all the data.
So look at what happens here.
So here's the same data.
So I just tell you I know that
in a population,
given what I've calculated in
the '90s there,
I know what fraction of the
people have this cost and that
alertness,
what fraction of the people are
so close to dumb that their
costs are astronomical and their
alertness is tiny,
what fraction of the people
have almost no cost and a very
high alertness,
so I'm only estimating four
parameters because I'm assuming
it's normally distributed.
Given that fixed pool of people
I apply that to the beginning of
every single mortgage and I just
crank out what would those guys
do.
In the tree if they knew what
the volatilities were when would
they decide to prepay,
and then I have to follow a
scenario out in the future and I
say,
"Well, along this path
which guy would prepay and which
guy wouldn't prepay and what
would the total prepayments look
along that path?"
And so this has generated the
pink line from the model with no
knowledge of the world except I
fit those parameters and look
how close it is to what actually
happened.
So it turns out that it was
incredibly easy to predict,
contingently predict what
prepayments were going to be and
therefore to be able to value
mortgages.
And this was a secret that not
many people,
you know, a bunch of people
understood,
but not that many understood,
and so for years we were
trading at our hedge fund,
first at Kidder and then at
Ellington with this ability to
contingently forecast
prepayments at a very high rate.
And why was it so stable,
the prediction,
and so reliable?
It's because the class of
people stayed pretty much the
same and every year there'd be
the same kinds of people with
the same kinds of behavior.
Some were very alert.
Some were very not alert,
but the distribution of types
was more or less the same and
you could predict with pretty
good accuracy what was going to
happen from year to year.
Of course, then after 2003 or
so the class of people started
to radically change and many
more people who never got
mortgages before got them and it
became much harder to predict
what they were going to do.
But so in the old days it was
pretty easy to predict.
And why was it so easy to
predict?
Because it was an agent based
model, agent based.
So, by the way,
I added this volatility here,
so these guys who just ran
regressions they had to have a
volatility or something
parameter.
So you see as volatility goes
up the prepayments are slower.
Well, they just had to notice
that and build it right into
their function.
I didn't even have to think of
that or burnout.
None of those things did I have
to think about because if you're
a guy optimizing here and
volatility goes up,
so you reset the tree so that
the interest rates can change
faster.
The option is worth more so
you're going to wait longer.
You're not going to just
exercise it right away because
you've got a chance that prices
will really go up so you can
wait a little longer,
afford to wait longer.
So prepayments will slow down.
So all I'm saying,
all of this is just to say that
if you have the right--
so it's agent based,
it's contingent predictions,
those two things together
enable you to make quite
reliable predictions about the
future if you're in a stable
environment.
And so what seems like a
bewildering amount of stuff
turns out to be pretty easy to
explain.
So now what happens?
So do you have any questions
here or should I--yes?
Student: You said you
assume that those two parameters
are normally distributed.
Did you select among some sort
of variance?
Prof: Some sort of what?
Student: Variance.
Prof: I had to figure
out what the mean and the
variance is.
There's mean and variance of
cost and mean and variance of
alertness to get that
distribution,
right?
So how do I know what the
population--so let me just put
the picture up again.
So who are the hyper rational
guys?
They are the people with the
really high alertness up there
and the really low cost,
so they're the guys back there.
They're the hyper--or maybe it
was the guys,
you know, one of these corners
with very high alertness and
very low cost.
I forgot which way the scale
works.
It might be going down.
So anyway, the guys with very
high alertness and very low
costs are the hyper rational
people.
At the other corner you've got
the guys who have very low
alertness and very high costs.
They're the people who you're
going to make a lot of money on
if you're the bank.
So how do I know how many
people are of each type?
Well, I don't.
I have to fit this distribution.
But you see I have so much data.
I've got this kind of curve.
This kind of curve I've got for
every starting year for the
whole history and there's so
many different interest rates
and so many different--
so I'm applying that same
population at the beginning of
every single curve and then
seeing what happens to my
prediction versus what really
happened.
So I've got thousands,
and thousands,
and thousands of data points
and only four parameters to fit.
So I pick the four parameters
to fit the data as much as
possible.
If I assumed everybody was
perfectly alert instead of that
curve that I showed you,
I put a huge crowd here of
perfectly rational people then I
would have found that I would
have gotten prepayments at 100
percent up there and at 0 all
the way over here and so it
wouldn't have fit that curve.
So that's how I knew that there
couldn't be that many perfectly
rational people.
Yes?
Student: How can you
know for sure that there are
only two patterns?
Prof: You mean how do I
know cost and alertness,
maybe there's some other
factors?
Yes, well there probably are
other factors.
So what would you
commonsensically think are the
factors?
What keeps people from
prepaying?
I think the most obvious one is
it's a huge hassle and they're
not paying attention.
So those are the first two that
I thought of.
Could you think of another one?
Student: Maybe their age.
Prof: Their age, exactly.
So maybe demography has an
effect on it.
So maybe, for example,
you get more sophisticated the
older you get.
So that was another factor we
put in.
So I'm not telling you all the
factors, but these were the two
main factors.
Another factor was growing
sophistication.
We called it the smart factor.
That's another factor.
So over time you get more
sophisticated.
So anyway, the point is with a
few of these factors you got a
pretty good fit,
and it was pretty reliable,
and you could predict what was
going to happen contingently.
So now if you want to trade
mortgages what are some of the
interesting things that happen?
The first interesting thing to
notice is that what do you think
happens as the interest rate
goes down?
So the first thing to notice
is--so I'll just ask you two
questions.
Let's go on the other side.
I'm running out of room.
Suppose that you have the
mortgage value,
what you get in the tree?
So in this tree that we've
built, here's the tree,
it's going like that,
and at every node we're
predicting--
for each class of people we're
predicting where his 1s are.
So that class is prepaying.
The other class is not as smart
so they're not prepaying here,
but maybe when things get
really low they'll start
prepaying here.
So each class of people,
each cost, alertness type has
its own tree.
They're the same tree,
but it's own behavior on the
tree, and then I add them all
together.
So what happens with the
starting interest rate?
So here we had .06 and this
value was 98 or something,
right?
Now, suppose the interest rate
went down to .05.
I drew this picture of interest
and mortgage value.
What do you think happens?
So the interest starts--this is
'98,6 percent is there.
As the interest rate goes down
what do you think happens to the
value of the mortgage?
If you're a bank and you've
fixed--the mortgage rate is 8
percent.
That's a fixed mortgage rate,
but now you've moved in the
tree from here to here.
Do you think your mortgage is
going to go up in value or down
in value?
Student: It's going up.
Prof: It's going to go
up because the interest rates
are lower and the present value
of the payments is getting
higher.
So if the interest rate goes
down the mortgage is going to go
up like that,
typically.
But will it keep going up like
this and this?
If it were a bond it would go
up like that,
right?
A bond, a 1 year bond which
owed 1 over 1 r would keep going
up and up the value before it
got negative,
say.
It would go up.
As r got negative it would go
way up like that.
So does the mortgage keep going
up like that?
As the interest rate goes down
is the value of the mortgage
going to get higher and higher
and higher?
Suppose the guy's optimal,
what's going to happen?
This is 100 here.
What'll happen?
Yep?
Student: He's going to
prepay.
Prof: He's going to
eventually figure out that he
should prepay so it'll go like
this.
If he's perfectly optimal he'll
never let it go above 100.
So it's going to go something
like this.
As the interest rate gets
higher you get crushed,
and as the interest rate gets
lower you don't get the full
upside because he's prepaying at
100.
He's never letting it go above
100, right?
So if he's not so optimal maybe
your value will go up,
but not so astronomically high.
So this idea that the mortgage
curve, instead of being like
this goes like that,
this is what was called
negative convexity.
Now, the next thing to know is
suppose that the guys are partly
irrational so it's going above
100.
So it's starting to go like
this.
Then what do you think?
As the interest gets really low
what's going to happen?
All right, you just said it, so.
If the guy was rational,
perfectly rational it would go
like that.
He'd never let it go above 100,
but now suppose guys are not
totally rational?
What's going to happen is
they're going to,
sort of--as rates get a little
bit low they're going to
overlook the fact that they
should prepay.
So now it's advantageous to you.
Things are worth more than 100,
but if rates get incredibly low
even the dumbest guy,
the highest cost guy is going
to realize he has an advantage
to prepay and so things are
going to go back down like that.
So the value's going to be
quite complicated.
So this is the mortgage value
as a function of interest rates.
Just common sense will tell you
this.
In a typical bond as the
interest rate gets lower the
present value gets higher.
You should expect a curve like
that, but because of the option
if it were rationally exercised
the curve would never get above
100.
It would have to go like that.
But now if people are
irrational you can take
advantage of them and get more
than 100 out of them.
But if the situation gets so
favorable to you it becomes
blindingly obvious,
eventually to them,
that they're getting screwed,
and eventually they act and
bring it all the way back to 100
again.
So this value of the mortgage
looks like that.
So that's a very tricky thing.
I'll even write, very tricky.
So if you don't know what
you're doing you could easily
get yourself hurt holding
mortgages.
You could suddenly find
yourself losing money holding
mortgages.
So that's my next subject here.
I want to talk about hedging.
So we know something now about
valuing mortgages.
Now I want to talk about
hedging, and what hedge funds
do, and what everyone on Wall
Street should be doing which is
hedging.
So if you hold a mortgage
you're going to hold it because
maybe you can lend 100 to a
bunch of people but actually get
a value that's more than 100.
So it looks like you're here,
but if interest rates change a
little bit suddenly this huge
value you thought you had might
collapse back down to 100,
or the interest rates might go
up and it might collapse to way
below 100.
So you look like you're well
off, but there are scenarios
where you could lose money and
you want to protect yourself
against that.
So how do you go about doing it?
What does hedging mean?
And I want to put it in the
context, the old context of the
World Series which we started
with before.
So it's easier to understand
there,
and so many of you will have
thought about this before so
you'll be able to answer it,
but if I put it in the mortgage
context it would seem just too
difficult.
I don't know why I did that.
So the World Series--I'm going
to lower it in a second.
So suppose that the Yankees
have a 60 percent chance,
I said beating the Dodgers,
I thought the Dodgers would be
in the World Series,
a 60 percent chance of winning
any game against the Phillies in
the World Series.
And you are a bookie and your
fellow bookies all understand
that it's 60 percent.
So some naive Philly fan comes
to you and says I want to bet
100 dollars that the Phillies
win the World Series.
Should you take the bet or not?
Yes you should take the bet
because 60 percent of the time
you're going to win 100
dollars--no.
Yes you should take the bet.
If he bet on one game you would
make, with 60 percent
probability you'd win 100 and
with 40 percent probability
you'd lose 100.
So that means on average your
expectation is equal to 20.
So if he's willing to bet 100
dollars on the Phillies winning
the first game of the series
with you,
you know that your expected
chance of winning is 20 dollars.
You're expecting to win 20
dollars from the guy.
Now, suppose he's willing to
make the same bet,
100 dollars for the entire
series?
What's your chance of winning
and what's your expected profit
from him?
Is it less than 20,20,
or more than 20?
Student: More than 20.
Prof: More than 20.
It's going to turn out to be,
so a 7 game series,
it's going to turn out to be 42
which we're going to figure out
in a second.
But what's your risk?
What's your risk?
In either case you might lose
100 dollars.
The Phillies,
they're probably going to lose,
but there's a chance something
goes crazy and some unknown guy
hits five home runs in the first
four games or something,
and some other unknown guy hits
another four home runs and you
lose the World Series.
You could lose 100 dollars,
and maybe the guy's not betting
100 dollars but 100 thousand
dollars or a hundred million
dollars.
You know you've got a favorable
bet, but you don't want to run
the risk of losing even though
there's not that high a chance
you're going to lose.
What can you do about it?
Well, you know that there are
these other bookies out there
who every game are willing to
bet at odds 60/40 either
direction on the Phillies or the
Yankees because they just all
know--
they're just like you.
You all know that the odds are
60 percent for the Yankees
winning every game.
So suppose this naive guy,
the Phillies fan,
comes up to you and bets 100
dollars on the World Series that
the Phillies will win.
You don't want to run the risk
of losing 100 dollars.
You know there are these other
bookies who are willing to take
bets a game at a time 60/40
odds.
What should you be doing?
What would you do?
Yes?
Student: Bet on the
Phillies winning because they
give you better odds so you're
guaranteed your profit.
Prof: So what would you
do?
So this guy's come to you,
and you're not going to be able
to give the--
we're going to find out exactly
what you should do in one
second,
but let's just see how far you
can get by reason without
calculation.
So this guy's come to you and
said, "I'm betting 100
dollars on the Phillies winning
the World Series."
This is the night before the
first game.
Every bookie is standing by
ready to take bets at 30 to 20
odds.
What would you do?
Student: You'd bet with
the bookie that the Phillies
would win because...
Prof: That what?
Student: That the
Phillies would win.
Prof: Yeah, how much?
Student: 100 dollars.
Prof: You'd bet the
whole 100 dollars?
Student: Well,
you get better odds,
so.
Prof: But would you bet
the whole 100 dollars on the
first game?
The guy's only bet 100 dollars
on the whole series.
Student: You'd bet 80
>
dollars.
Prof: So it's not so
obvious what to do,
right, but he's got exactly the
right idea.
You can hedge your bet.
So here we are.
I shouldn't have put that down.
Don't tell me I turned it off.
That would just kill me.
God, I meant to hit mute.
I think I hit off.
Oh, how dumb?
So you would bet on the--while
that warms up.
I can see it.
All right, so what happens is
you'll have a tree which looks
like this and like this,
like this and like this and
let's say we go out a few games
like this.
Now, this is a 1,2,
3 game series.
All right, so I've done it.
Here's the start of World
Series.
This is the World Series
spreadsheet you had before.
Now, here's the start.
Here's game 1,2, 3,4, 5,6, 7.
So if the Yankees win the
series they get 100 dollars.
You get 100 dollars, sorry.
Oh, what an idiot.
So every time you end up above
the start, win more than you
lose, you get 100 dollars.
On the other hand,
if you lose more than you win
you lose 100 dollars,
and so ctrl,
copy.
Here is losing 100 dollars.
So now this tree,
remember from doing it before,
is just by backward induction.
If you look at this thing up
there it says you get,
60 percent I think was the
number we figured out over here,
so right?
So 60 percent is the
probability of the Yankees
winning a game.
So you take any node like this
one you're always taking 60
percent of the value up here
plus 40 percent of the value
here.
So if you do that you find out
that the value to you is 42
dollars, just what we said.
So let's put that in the middle
of the screen.
So the value is 42 dollars.
Now, if the Yankees win the
first game you're in much better
shape.
So winning the first game means
you moved up to this node here.
All of a sudden you went from
42 dollars to 64 dollars.
And if the Yankees lost the
first game you would have gone
down to that value which is like
9 dollars.
Your expected winnings when the
Yankees are down a game,
you know, they're still a
better team so actually it's
more likely even after losing
the first game that the Yankees
would still win the series.
So you see the risk that you're
running and you can calculate
this.
So what should you do in the
very first game?
This tells you that your
expected winnings is 42.
Of course .6 times 64 that's
38.4 .4 times 9 is 3.6.
That is 42 dollars.
So that's 42 because it's the
average of this and this,
and 64 is the average of .6 of
this and .4 of that.
So what should you do?
Well, on average you're going
to make 42 dollars.
What's the essence of hedging?
You want to guarantee that you
make 42 dollars no matter what
happens.
No matter who wins the series
you want to end up with 42 extra
dollars assuming the interest
rate is 0 from the beginning to
the end of the series.
So how can you arrange that?
What can you do?
Well, so that's the mystery.
I'll give you one second to try
and think it through.
You should get this.
What would you do here?
Are there no baseball bookies
in the--yep?
Student: Didn't we just
bring this up before like with
our hedge funds?
Can we put something else aside
that you view at a percentage
rate that you think you can
trust and then you can trust the
rest of it to whatever the real
probabilities are?
Prof: Well,
you can bet with another bookie
at 60 to 40 odds.
If the Yankees win the first
game you're just doing great.
If the Yankees lose the first
game you're looking to be in a
little bit of trouble.
So the point is you're not
going to get the payoffs until
the very end either plus 100 or
minus 100,
but already by the first game
you're either doing better than
you were before or worse than
you were before.
You're already,
in effect, suffering some risk
at the very beginning.
So this is one of the great
ideas of finance.
You shouldn't hedge the final
outcome.
You should hedge next day's
If you're marking to market
that's what you'd have to do.
Marking to market you'd have to
say my position now--my bet is
worth 64 dollars.
The Yankees lost the first
game, the bet would be worth 9
dollars.
So what does it mean to protect
yourself?
Not just protect yourself
against what's happening at the
end,
that's really what you want to
do, but in order to do that you
should protect yourself every
day against what could happen.
So every day you should end up
with 42 here and 42 there
because, after all,
that's what you're trying to
lock in.
No matter who wins the first
game you should still say I'm 42
dollars ahead because I got
myself in this position.
So how could you do that?
Well, let's bet at 3 to 2 odds,
right, 60/40 is 3 to 2 odds.
Let's make a bet with another
bookie at 22 and 33 here.
So 22--I put it in the wrong
place.
This is the 33 and this is 22,
but plus 33 and minus 22.
So what are you doing here?
Notice that this is 2 times 11,
this is 3 times 11.
This is 60/40 odds.
I'm betting on the Phillies.
If the Phillies win one game I
collect 33 dollars.
That's what I should do that he
said.
He said, "Go to the bookie
across the street and bet on one
game, not the whole series.
Bet on one game with that
bookie across the street,
33 dollars versus 22
dollars."
Let's say you can only bet 1
game at a time with the other
bookies,
actually, maybe you were saying
all along bet on the whole
series,
but let's say you can only bet
one game at a time with the
other bookies.
You'd bet 33 dollars on the
Phillies in the first game.
That naive Philly fan has put
up 100 dollars on the series.
You're, in the first game,
going to put 33 dollars.
You've taken his bet so you're
hoping the Yankees win,
but that's bad to be in a
position where you have to hope.
You don't want to do that.
So you take his bet on the
Phillies because he's given you
100 to 100 odds.
That's even odds even though
you know the Yankees have a 60
percent change of winning.
You go to the bookie across the
street and you bet at 60/40 odds
on the Phillies,
but you don't bet the whole
100.
You only bet 33 dollars of it.
So if you win you get 33
dollars.
If you lose you only have to
pay the guy 22.
So what's going to happen?
After the first day this
position is going to be worth 42
and this position is also going
to be worth 42,
exactly where you started.
So because a win in the first
game is going to put you so far
ahead in your bet with the first
naive Philly better,
and a loss in the first game is
going to put you so far behind,
you hedge that possibility by
going 33/22 in favor of the
Phillies.
You take a big bet on the
Yankees and then you make a
smaller bet on the Phillies that
cancels out part of the big bet
on the Yankees,
but you've made the two at
different odds and so on net
you're still going to be 42
dollars ahead.
Let's just pause for a second
and see if you got that.
So by doing this you can't
possibly lose any money.
And now you're going to repeat
this bet down here and here.
So in the next--you see where
do things go next?
Here you're down 8 dollars.
If you lost again you'd be down
32 dollars.
Now things would really be bad.
After the Yankees lost two
games in a row your original bet
would look terrible,
but things aren't so bad
because you bet on the Phillies
here.
You already made 33 dollars.
So how much money do you think
you should be betting on the
Phillies down here?
Well, you want to lock in 42
dollars at every node no matter
what happens.
This 42 dollars,
by making the right offsetting
bet you can keep 42 everywhere,
here until the very end,
and so no matter what happened
you can always end up with 42
dollars.
That's the essence of hedging.
So let's just say it again what
the idea is.
It's a great idea and we don't
have time to go through all the
details, but the great idea is
this.
You've made some gigantic bet
with somebody.
Why do you bet with anybody?
Because you think you know more
than they do.
The whole essence of trading
and finance is you think you
understand the world better than
somebody else.
So understand it means you
think something's going to turn
out one way that the other guy
doesn't really know is going to
happen.
So you're making a bet on
whether you're right or wrong.
So when you say you know you
don't know for sure.
You just have a better idea
than he does,
so you want to use your idea
without running the risk.
So how can you do it?
If your idea is really correct
there may be a way so that you
can eliminate the luck.
So here if you really know the
odds are 60/40,
your class of bookies knows the
and some other guys who doesn't
know thinks the odds are 50/50
and is willing to bet against
you,
you can lock in your 42 dollars
for sure.
You don't just take a bet and
hope you win.
You can take a bet and then
hedge it to lock in your profit
for sure,
step by step,
and that's what we have to
explain how that dynamic hedging
works.
So I have to stop.